-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you so much
for coming back on the show.
-Oh, please, James Kanye Fallon,
we adore doing your show.
[ Laughter ]
You know, and so of all
the late night shows,
this is the easiest one
to fall asleep to.
-Thank you so much.
-[ Laughter ]
-First of all, I think that
your comedy is just brilliant.
I do.
I was watching the monologue.
To me, your comedy is
like crypto.
I don't understand it,
but I admire it.
[ Laughter ]
But really, tell everyone what
you were -- what you were
telling about why it's finally
the right time
to suspend the Constitution.
What did that mean?
-[ Laughter ]
-I don't want to get into it.
-Jimmy.
-Yeah?
-If Marty starts
humping your leg,
it's best to just let him
finish.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-It's gotten me through a lot of
flights and dinners,
I'll tell you that.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And all I got to say --
I know this is not right.
First, I say, your beard --
I was going to make a little fun
of it because I thought at
first, it looked like, you know,
a COVID mask that they cut
a mouth hole in.
[ Laughter ]
I actually love the beard.
I really do.
I miss the cold sore,
but I like the beard.
[ Laughter ]
-You miss the cold sore?
-When I grow a beard, I look
like the guy in the Western
that goes, "Dag nab it."
[ Laughter ]
-No, I'm not used to your beard.
It's kind of jarring in person.
It's like seeing Steve
with a tan.
You know, because --
[ Laughter ]
Steve is whiter
than a Mormon golf team.
[ Laughter ]
But you look great.
You look like the offspring
if Santa had sex with an elf.
-Oh, thank you so much.
-[ Laughter ]
-It makes you look like
a cool youth minister.
-Oh, thank you.
-But honestly, I think you do
look like -- you look like you
bathed in testosterone.
-Yeah, you do.
-And I'll tell you what.
It's given you that buff
Marjorie Taylor Greene physique.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much.
-Wow. What a compliment.
-I'm excited that you guys
are -- you're hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with musical guest
Brandi Carlile.
-That's right.
-That's a big deal.
-Very big deal.
-This is a big deal.
-She's a genius, you know.
-And the truth,
we are very busy.
But we always have time
to come down here
and do five to seven minutes
with you and...
[ Laughter ]
...possibly ruin our careers
and destroy everything
that we built.
-Well, it's appreciated.
-It's always a risk.
But it is exc-- I mean,
I don't -- you know, Steve and I
think of ourselves as the Lennon
and McCartney of comedy.
-Oh.
-No one else does, but we do.
-Oh, that's good.
-[ Laughter ]
Steve, are you going to play the
banjo on "Saturday Night Live"?
-No, I'm not.
-You're not playing?
-No.
-Oh. Why not?
-I'll tell you why.
Because the cast voted.
[ Laughter ]
-I see, yeah.
-No, listen, when he pulls out
his banjo, people in China beg
for lockdowns.
-That's interesting.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, you're here.
I thought everyone
had wandered off.
-I'm here too.
-I forgot.
-You can't just put me down
and then ignore me.
-I want to say, I saw a very
funny promo that you guys did
for hosting
"Saturday Night Live" this week.
It was so funny, I want to show
everyone here.
Do you mind?
-Absolutely.
-That's what it's for.
-That's true. You're right.
Here's Steve Martin
and Martin Short.
Here's the promo for "Saturday
Night Live" this weekend.
[ Elevator bell dings ]
♪♪
[ Muffled groaning ]
-[ Gasps ] Water. I need water.
[ Choking ]
-Hey. Hi.
It is such an honor.
I'm so excited to meet you two.
-Likewise, big fan.
Ugh!
-I grew up watching your movies.
The "Three Amigos!" and --
-Could you get me a green tea
with extra ice?
-Oh, I'm -- I'm actually one of
the cast members.
-Oh! Oh, yeah.
With a holiday cup?
-Holiday cup?
Got it.
-Can't breathe.
-Hi, I'm Martin Short,
and Steve and I are so excited
to be hosting
"Saturday Night Live" this week
with the great Brandi Carlile.
-Steve, got your green tea.
-Aaah!
-Thanks.
-Come on. That's how you do it.
That is fantastic.
-Thank you.
-That is so good.
I loved it so much.
-Thank you.
-I cannot wait for this weekend.
Are you guys
in the holiday spirit?
-I am.
-I looked in the monitor,
and this is like
Margaret Hamilton wore these
in "The Wizard of Oz."
Look at that.
[ Laughter ]
It's this thing.
-Yeah, I remember that.
[ Laughter continues ]
Oh, my God.
Auntie Em, Auntie Em.
-And I'll tell you
another thing.
Those aren't socks.
-[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no. My gosh.
-I have the worst rash. Yeah.
-But I have noticed, actually,
that I find this so sweet
about New Yorkers.
They take their mittens, and
they cut a hole in their mittens
so they can still give
each other the finger.
[ Laughter ]
-But it's difficult.
I mean, I never --
Steve and I are very close,
and I never know what to get you
for Christmas because of
the whole atheist thing.
[ Laughter ]
Although he's in the spirit.
He's already hung
his compression stockings
by the chimney with care.
[ Laughter ]
-I will say that my favorite
part of decorating the tree is
when at the end, I just put
a little tiny star on top.
And thank you for being up there
because --
[ Laughter ]
I know that can get
uncomfortable.
-Oh, my God.
But, you know, office parties.
This is when STDs can be spread,
you know?
But I don't think of them
as a disease.
I think of them as regifting.
[ Laughter ]
And I love this -- when
New York -- when there's snows
in New York, the whole city
looks like Donald Trump Jr.'s
desk.
[ Laughter ]
I did that for the band.
-Yes!
♪♪
-You guys have such
a long history.
You've worked professionally
together for --
-We have. And we have been
together so long,
we can actually finish
each other's careers.
[ Laughter ]
-We're like the co-anchors
on "Good Morning America"
without the office sex,
you know.
-Yeah.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Are you still touring --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you!
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
Oh, you're still here?
-Yeah.
-Yes, we're all --
-I wish I had something
to bow for.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you still touring
with the show?
Your show is called
"You Won't Believe What They
Look Like Today!"
-Yes, that's true.
-Are you still touring?
-Well, it's fun --
-Yes.
-It's fun.
I love touring with Steve.
But, you know, at his age,
there are certain problems.
You know, I mean, when the
curtain goes up, Steve says,
"I'm ready, Jesus!"
And he starts heading
toward the light, you know?
-Interesting.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Loudly ] I was telling people
how sometimes you get confused.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Steve!
-Yeah.
-We toured --
Right before COVID started,
we were touring Ireland.
-Oh, that's fun.
-Yeah, but we had to leave
suddenly because [Laughs]
Marty couldn't say "air lingus"
without giggling.
[ Laughter ]
-You both got a bunch of things
going on.
"Only Murders in the Building,"
come on.
How great is that show?
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is unbelievable.
-Thank you.
-TV at its finest.
-Go ahead and bow.
-Yeah, now you got to bow.
-Give them your bow.
-No, not like I'm not in it.
-No, you co-created it
or created or whatever you did.
You should take the bow.
It's true. It's his idea.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a bow.
-Yeah.
-You're hosting
"Saturday Night Live" --
-I'm not going to bow like you
because I don't need to.
-Wow!
[ Audience oohs ]
-Steve, you have this fantastic
memoir, by the way.
-Oh, thank you.
-Oh, look at that.
-"Number One Is Walking."
Congratulations on this.
This is a fantastic memoir.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
Memoirs, your time in movies.
Marty, you're in the "Beauty and
The Beast: 30th Anniversary."
You are playing Lumiere.
-Lumiere.
[ French accent ]
Be our guest. Be our guest.
This is our service
to the guest.
[ Normal voice ] And of course,
the fabulous H.E.R.,
who will be out soon is Belle.
She's Belle.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys have
never been busier.
-Yes, we're busier than Nick
Cannon's child-support lawyer.
-[ Laughter and applause ]
-Congrats on everything.
Steve Martin, Martin Short,
everybody.
Catch them hosting "Saturday
Night Live" this weekend
with musical guest
Brandi Carlile.
Steve, Martin, and I are playing
a fun game when we come back.
Stick around.